now here's a fever this is process of
finding the finder quit interception and
then therefore puppy into this other
form it's a little bit awkward I don't
really need to know this point I really
want the line that's what can I go
directly dead that would be more
efficient so that's what this method is
that I'm about to show you think of
something yummy which is a more
efficient path what I'm trying to go for
here is I have to solve this question we
had to solve this question of finding a
concurrent mind with this intermediate
step and it took some time right in fact
those people had much more working then
I'd you zero awaken we can go directly
there go straight from the equations to
this line is the first thing I want to
point out I started to solve by
elimination okay to find the point of
intersection but there are lots of other
ways that you can combine l1 and l2
do you notice that for instance I can
just say equation what was equated to
that's another way that's legitimate to
combine them so if I say that right
there with me what happens I'm gonna add
the left-hand side then I'm going to add
the right-hand side so this is what it
looks like he is the left hand side of
equation 1 he is the left hand side of
equation 2 what's the right hand side
equals here great now what happens when
we go and bash through it's how many X's
do you get just click like this one for
them and I want
and what's the cousin okay now does this
work out I could pull beyond three down
one more time but I'm not going to I can
quickly test out that this works does it
plus through negative 1 1 negative 1 1
this will become negative 4 plus 1 which
is negative 3 you add 3 sure enough you
get 0 so it works that's reassuring
this one TD problem then what are these
right I mean we just saw that the
animation show us all the different
versions depending on whatever grading
we wanted right but I've only got one
here I want to get all the rest of them
so here is really clever way to overcome
this problem and have to do example
general Falls means that it's equal to 0
right the reason why that's so useful to
use I can multiply this by anything I
like any cuts it that I like and it's
still the same equation for instance I
could have 2x + 2 dy plus 2 C and the
right hand side would still be 0
do you agree same wine haven't got any
values to it that means would I do this
right instead of doing this I'm not just
going to add equation 2 I'm going to add
a multiple of equation to see what
happens I need to choose a letter to be
by multiple and I want to be anything
because I know the line can be anything
so I'm going to choose no no no okay
plays a pretty cockatrice for a constant
so I would play lots of that equation ok
there if you have a look at this I'm
going to add the left hand side of
equation 1 just like I did before
through the MedX
then instead of adding 3x minus y plus 4
I'm going to add K lots of them I've
added left inside and K lots of the
left-hand side of this sorry let's
decide one came optimal episode 2 what
happens on the right it's still 0 but to
clarify Y and 0 I want to show the
right-hand side of question 1 0 the
right hand side of equation 2 ends up
being 0 but it didn't like we've done
something to it
don't flip it to us so I'm gonna like
this now this is crucial
even though it's nothing they're not
making a difference to our working this
is why were using general form you can't
do this trick with any of the other
forms because you get done something
different with the right hand side now
I'll just simplify out I don't really
grant it anymore
I can expand this guy here I'm going to
write into 3 KX by this over here KY
plus okay okay
the reason I've done this it's just to
make another way easier to again just
like I sided with put this equation in
general form I've got the right hand
side be 0 what else I did to make this
general form I have all I have like six
times over there how many words supposed
to have really really swift they're free
I need to know how the XS rewind and
what the constant is
so tell me how many X's there are
there's 3k of the PR millions and then
there's one here do you agree that's how
many X's I've got some that express that
like so that's how many X's there are no
no no excuse me I'm gonna do the same
thing for watch how many Y's do I have
I have two of them here and I have minus
K of them over there yes
so 2 minus K tell me why I got all right
lastly look the constant 2 + 4 + - done
you obviously don't need the brackets
will be in there - 4 K minus 1 but I
like to do that to sort of make it clear
this beside a b c in case i need to do
something like particular businesswoman
or whatever okay so Tennessee crevasse
this workout that should be far enough
just don't see that help me see if this
is going to work let's get rid of that
guy what's this equation down here we
start with how many X's where there
again 3 good so drink a plus one push
okay now again just like before it says
you want to add that in we will in a
second I'll come back to it how many Y's
other humans get and then that customers
was four orders or cameras one before
the way I did forget the one minus one
equals what because it's general form
so I'm going to add that slider in okay
so the first good sign is and how thick
it's concurrent with the others right
but then what happens is I vary K
because K is a thing that I can change
well looks like we did it right okay so
this thing is really nice because I do I
don't even know what the point of
intersection is but I can still find
that all of the lines that go through
this point now that's nice because he
are the point of intersection was easy
to find guess how often the problem
interpretations to be easy to find
answer not that often I I crafted this
to give you really nice simple numbers
okay but if these are gross things if it
fractures if there's rational stop in
there that you're going to be in some
trouble this process lets you go
completely around this you don't solve
never solve simultaneously which is kind
of advantageous right it's just quick
all right now link it pause on that when
it comes to just learn all right let me
see if I can either here's the last
thing which is an item right before to
this critter all this values K is
special this value of captures is
actually the projective exhibit hardness
the screaming enhancing this Harley okay
is zero
what's special about K equals zero have
a look at the dagger with K equals zero
paint background something I think what
K was Taylor's how many lots of equated
to do you one so k zero that means I
don't want any of equation should so
what do you get left with you get left
with equation one so let's tie this all
up in a nicely folks this process that
we just learnt have a name the very very
imaginative name it is called the K
method because the other name is finding
the equation of a like account with two
other lines without finding the point of
intersection bit of a mouthful so K
messes days after decade right there how
he summarizes if you have two lines in
general form right so it is format here
that's right like this give as this line
and this line both equal to 0 I can
avoid working at the point of
intersection I know straight to my clear
line doing this scene if you
so let's state this simultaneous
equations of step with algebra right
give an l1 equal 0 del 2 equals 0
what's the format of this line right
here looks like this to me you've got l1
untouched and over there you've got K
lots of the second line and of course
because the general form is the right
hand sides are all 0 what do you get on
this right hand side this light here is
Kiko
right so you can charge your back me
down without fighting the point of
intersection if K is equal to zero you
end up with l1 which means that if you
wanted to if you didn't have to have it
in this order you could have written it
like this and it would have given you
the same result
okay but most people remember like this
because why would you put the numbers in
order okay so it put a big box and some
color and highlight around that this is
probably the most important partner to
party driven write down one of the
notable absences from the reference
sheet why is this or the reference sheet
because all it is is just to use a
particular use of the general form which
you need to know it is is on there and
then you can derive the rest of it all
right as brand going one last little
point before I such as well and I this
is cool
could it all the line every single line
the click home with this what if we did
want a specific one what if we wanted
the one that goes through say passing
through pick a point any point one one I
heard one one day and in fact the signal
to how do I find the particular line is
every one of them of these passes
through one one what will I do
our son teach it is x equals one and y
was one watch what happens okay there's
the line down there okay what x equals
one what you get that's just three k
plus one yes when y equals one you just
get okay and then you've got this guy
over here okay
can you add them constants for me
constants one two five five
sorry little bit of trainer to implement
you're just going to get to I don't you
you'll get two on this side but I'm
going to get him over here because I
need to solve for K so I'm going to
subtract two from both sides okay now
tell me how many came there up good for
the shape of great so what's K negative
on earth okay let's have a look
hey wait stinky [ __ ] at those leave it
leave it
huh of course it is isn't it what was
that point of intersection we found
earlier it's negative one one so you
have to be horizontal to get you you
happy